would you say that all of us are capable
of spreading any story
sort of the the soldier knitson
idea of um
that all of us are capable of Good and
Evil the the line between good and evil
runs the heart of every man
yes I wouldn't say that every person is
capable of every type of evil but we are
all valuable
there is a large element it partly
depends on the efforts we make to
develop our self-awareness during life
uh part of it depends on moral luck
you know if you are born as a Christian
German
uh in the 1910s OR 1920s when you grow
up in Nazi Germany that's bad moral luck
your chances of committing terrible
things you have a very high chance of
doing it and you can withstand it but it
will take tremendous effort if you're
born in Germany after the war you're
morally lucky the you will not be put to
such a test you will not need to exert
this enormous efforts not to commit
atrocities
so there isn't this is just part of
history there there is an element of of
luck but again part of it is also
self-awareness
and you asked me earlier about uh uh the
the potential of power to corrupt and I
listened to the interview you just did
with with prime minister Netanyahu a
couple of days ago and one of the things
that most struck me during the interview
that you asked him
you asked him are you afraid of of this
thing that that power corrupts he didn't
think for a single second he didn't pose
he didn't admit a tiny little uh level
of of you know a doubt of no Paul
doesn't corrupt it was for me it was it
was a shocking and in a revealing uh uh
moment and it kind of dovetails with how
you began the interview that I really
liked your opening Gambit
that kind of no really you kind of told
him you know lots of people in the world
are angry with you that some people hate
you they dislike you what do you want to
to to to tell to tell them to say to
them and you gave him this kind of
platform and
um I I was very what will he say and he
just denied it
he basically denied it you know he had
to cut show the interview from three
hours to one hour because you had
hundreds of thousands of Israelis in the
streets demonstrating against him and he
goes and say no everybody likes me what
are you talking about